según la embajada de Ucrania que en
Washington los temas principales en esta
reunión bilateral que de hecho es la
segunda reunión bilateral que tienen
persona persona por un excelente son los
siguientes primero el tema de las armas
estas misiles que Estados Unidos va a
entregar en este paquete de cerca de dos
mil millones de dólares que le entregará
a Estados Unidos a Ucrania además de El
eventual presupuesto del 2023 que es
cercano a los 45.000 millones de dólares
en ayuda militar Entonces el uno de los
temas centrales será es el tema de las
armas será también el tema de la energía
de sanciones y una estrategia para la
paz estos son los temas que según la
embajada se están tocando en este
momento en la reunión bilateral que
tienen acá en la casa blanca una vez
termine esta reunión será a las cuatro y
media de la tarde la rueda de prensa
También acá en la casa blanca y después
de eso
se trasladará al congreso donde hará en
plenaria un discurso muy esperado en
prime Time en televisión Estados Unidos
precisamente para buscar ese apoyo
bilateral sobre todo los republicanos
que precisamente antes de ganar la
mayoría en la cámara baja Pues están
diciendo y dijeron María en varias
ocasiones que querían reducir la ayuda
Ucrania para enfocar más el presupuesto
en los problemas y en los temas
nacionales
quieren que esto no sea así y que
precisamente estos cerca de 45.000
millones de dólares se han aprobados en
ayuda militar a Ucrania